let's get some additional information
tonight on the group of immigrants
headed toward the US border in that big
convoy that was referenced national
correspondent William la jeunesse is
monitoring developments from Los Angeles
a week ago a caravan of Central
Americans crossed from Guatemala into
Mexico bound for the US after having
crossed two checkpoints we haven't
performed another count but I estimate
that there are about 1,300 unlike most
immigrants who hire smugglers this group
is guided by people without borders a
u.s. nonprofit advertising the trip and
raising money online while also saying
it will provide legal advice on how
immigrants can claim asylum upon
reaching the u.s. we'll take them into
custody
will do hours worth of processing and
then we'll turn them over to ice and
then ice will release them based upon
what they call a credible fear eighty
percent of the caravan is from Honduras
most say they are fleeing violence and
poverty while that doesn't qualify as
persecution on account of race religion
nationality social group or political
opinion
studies show 88 percent who claim asylum
ultimately get their date in immigration
court let's make sure that if they do
come to the US border that they are able
to go through the full and fair process
of seeking asylum if that's what they
desire because of backlogs in the courts
shelter space and judicial rulings
immigrants can't be held indefinitely
that concerns President Trump who blames
ridiculous Liberal Democrat laws like
catch and release for the problem Sunday
he asked Mexico to stop the caravan
got to help us at the border they flow
right through Mexico they say to the
United States can't happen that way
anymore now Mexico did deport some
70,000 Central Americans last year
although historically they've been
allowed to pass through though it is
against Mexican law now the group is
likely to reach the u.s. in the next ten
days unless the Trump administration can
pressure Mexico to stop them first
otherwise I'm told they'll be processed
like anyone else claiming asylum
Brett William thank you